Ali, how you
>> Hello.
>> How you doing?
>> I'm good, man. I'm good. You're a
Muslim?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. I believe that Islam is
untrustworthy, man. Would you like to
know why?
>> No. I got I I just got some questions.
Is that okay?
>> It's okay after we deal with our topic.
We got to deal with our topic first and
then you can ask me whatever you want.
>> All right. Um,
>> so
>> I'm not like very religious, but
>> You're not very religious?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Uh, were you born into Islam?
>> Yeah. I mean, I practiced it for like
half my life.
Okay. Why do you believe it's
trustworthy?
>> Um I mean like
>> I'm a Shia. So I'm not like a Sunni. So
>> you're a Shia?
>> So I do good deeds.
>> You're a Shia Muslim
>> instead of like Yeah.
>> Okay. So Okay.
>> No, it's it's all good. So you're you're
a Shia Muslim. That's all right. You
sound young. Um
but so you said you've been p you've
been within Islam all your life
basically.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Would you trust a religion
that has corrupted scripture?
>> Yeah.
>> You would
>> sometimes. Maybe. Maybe. Maybe.
>> You would trust a religion with
corrupted scripture?
>> Yeah.
>> Why?
>> Cuz sometimes the books make mistakes.
Are you talking about the Hadith or the
Quran?
>> Quran. Any any revelation from Allah, if
they ended up being corrupted, are they
still trustworthy?
>> That's a hard question.
>> I think it's pretty easy. I I wouldn't
trust a religion that has corrupted
scripture. Like if if the scriptures
been changed and have mistakes in and
been tampered with, I don't think that
that th those books would be
trustworthy.
>> Yeah. I mean I mean I read the Bible
too. I liked it.
>> You like the Bible?
>> Yeah, it was pretty good.
>> What' you like about it?
>> Um like the quotes and everything like
very inspirational.
>> Have you read a little bit about Jesus?
>> Yeah.
>> What do you think about how the Bible
portrays Jesus?
>> I think it's a little bit different than
the Quran. It's very different. Yeah,
it's very very different. Jesus says
some amazing things in there. He teaches
like for example like things like to
love your neighbor pray for Yeah. love
your neighbor as yourself.
>> He even tells us to greet and pray for
our enemies and pray for those who like
curse us and persecute us and slander
us. He tells us to pray for those people
instead of fight them. What do you think
of that?
>> I think I believe that.
>> Then you don't believe the Quran. the
Quran.
>> I really like the Quran cuz it has good
authentic text. Um
>> like I would uh tell you to like read
the Quran for a little bit.
>> I have. I've read it all.
>> Oh, good.
>> Yeah, I've read the I read the Quran,
which is why I'm making I'm saying what
I'm saying. You know, I've read the
Quran. I've read what it says. Um I've
read how it appeals like it it points us
back to the scriptures that came before
it, right? like the Bible and uh like
the important thing is is that when we
read the Bible and we put it side by
side with the Quran, we see that the
Quran contradicts the Bible in a lot of
important places, you know.
>> Oh, yeah. I get it. I get it.
>> Here's a uh one of my favorite verses in
the Quran [clears throat] cuz I'm a
Christian so this verse resonates with
me. It's in chapter 5 verse uh 47. It
says, "Let the people of the gospel
judge by what Allah has revealed in it.
And whoever does not judge by what Allah
has revealed, then they're the
wrongdoers.
>> Right?
>> So the Quran tells me as a Christian
that I should use the gospel as my
judge. I have to judge by the gospel.
Right? Now, if I do that, then I have to
judge that the Quran is false because
the Quran goes against the gospel in in
very important places like Jesus not
being crucified, Jesus not being the son
of God, stuff like that.
>> Erased to heaven and I believe that.
Yeah,
>> because in the book he was a good man.
Maybe like one of the best prophets.
>> One of Oh, he's the best. There's nobody
on his level.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, but that but that's that's the
issue that I find is that so if I'm
going to if I'm going to judge by the
gospel like the Quran tells me to, I
have to conclude that the Quran is false
because it contradicts what the gospel
says. It it contradicts what Jesus said.
So,
>> can you give me an example of the
gospel?
>> Yeah. Yeah, sure. So, for example, if we
go to H if we go to let's go to uh
Matthew. We're going to go to Matthew
and we're going to do let's see hand it
over. Hand it over to the chief priests.
Let's see. Let's see. Okay, here it is.
All right. Matthew 20 19 verse 18 and
19. This is this is an example of the
gospel and what Jesus is teaching. It
says I'll start at verse 17. And it
says, "And Jesus was going up as Jesus
was going up to Jerusalem, he took up he
took up uh the 12 disciples aside." He
took the 12 disciples aside. And on the
way, he said to them, "See, we are going
up to Jerusalem." This is Jesus talking
to his disciples. "We're going up to
Jerusalem."
>> He says,
>> "Isn't one of their disciples like
Paul?"
>> No, no, like Matthew. Matthew's one of
the disciples.
>> Oh, Matthew. Yeah. He says, "See, we are
going up to Jerusalem, and the Son of
Man," he's talking about himself, the
Son of Man, "will be delivered over to
the chief priests and scribes, and they
will condemn him to death and deliver
him over to the Gentiles to be mocked
and flogged and crucified, and he will
be raised on the third day." So Jesus
here preaching in the gospel says that
he's going to be betrayed. He's going to
be handed over to the Romans
>> and they're going to flog him. They're
going to mock him and then they're going
to crucify him. But he's going to ra
rise again from the dead on the third
day. That's what Jesus taugh t t t t t t
t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t
t t t t t t t t t t t t t t, right?
Obviously the Quran teaches the
opposite, right? The Quran says no, he
wasn't crucified.
>> He raised to heaven. Yeah,
>> exactly. So we have two conflicting
things. Jesus teaches us that he is
going to be crucified and then rise
again from the dead. The Quran teaches
that he wasn't crucified, but it was
made to appear so, and then Allah took
him up to heaven.
>> So, if I'm going to if I have to if I'm
going to judge by the gospel, I have to
judge that the Quran got this wrong
because the gospel says that he is going
to be crucified and rise again. You see
the you see my point?
>> Yeah. So that that's why that's one of
the reasons why Islam within itself like
the Quran is it's not trustworthy
because it doesn't go it's not in line
with the gospel and the Torah and the
previous scriptures that came before it.
Does that make sense?
>> Oh, I get it. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, uh I I want to encourage you,
man, like keep listening. Keep
listening. Um I I I break a lot of this
stuff down. Matter of fact, you you'll
see a lot of this stuff with other other
Muslims that I'm going to have a
conversation with and and watch and see
how I break down this issue in full and
just keep learning and even take notes
if you want. Like mark down the verses
that I'm that I bring up.
>> Yeah, I just did. Thank you, bro.
>> Good. Good. Yep. So, this was Matthew
chapter 20 17 to 19. Okay, that's good.
All right. Take care, man. God bless
you, man. It was nice talking to you.
>> God bless you, too.
>> All right. Peace.
>> [clears throat]
>> Just plant plant little seeds, you know.
Plant little seeds. And we already got
20 something super chats. Good lord.
Planting little seeds. Make sure you
guys pray for pray for Ali there. Pray
for Ali. Seemed like he was uh you know
open to listening and I love that. So
let's pray for him and pray that he
continues to listen. Hopefully we talk
to him again. Yeah, Ali, you can you can
come back again and um and if you want
to ask some questions, we can talk
again. Let's go ahead and bring up
another guest. Derek, I need you to
connect or turn your camera on or
something. I don't know what's going on
there. Derek uh Ausu.
Derek Ousu. Derek Ousu. Planting. Yeah,
exact. Exactly. Warrior for Christ.
Planting little seeds, you know, some
light. You know, some light. Uh Kelly, I
think that's how to say it. You got to
connect. Hopefully, you're a mun. If you
can't connect, all right, I'll just
bring up somebody else. All right.
Before I bring up the next guest, let's
go ahead and get a couple of super
chats. I try to stay up to date with
them so I'm not like trying to cram them
all in at the end of the stream. Let's
see. Uh, Real Faith says, "Brother
Logic, love how God is using you. Big
inspiration for me. A small ch as a
small channel. I would love to get in
touch with you. God bless you. Keep
cooking." Uh, thank you, man. I
appreciate that. Yeah. Uh, just email
me, man. Let's let's let's talk. TK
Bronco says, "Hope you are good, GL.
While you are cooking, is it possible
for you to play us our favorite song,
Allah gave me faith?" Hello. God bless
you, brother. That song, ladies and
gentlemen, comes out at the right
moment. See, you things have to have
their timing or else they will get stale
and even irritable. It'll be irritating
just hearing it. It'll it'll get stale.
But when you bring it out at the right
time, then it's always fresh. It's
always ripe, you know. So, yes, the song
has to come out. It can't just come out
randomly and for no reason. It has to
come at the right time. All right. Uh,
Ladina says, "Check out Islam." Wow.
Random hadith site if you need to fill
any dull moments. Okay. Yeah, that
sounds good. We get that going. By the
way, again, guys, only come up if you
are a Muslim. Only request up if you're
a Muslim. Guys, please and thank you.
Oh, I did not mean to invite you.
Cancel. Yeah, cancel that invitation to
life life rants. Nobody wants him to
join.
>> Hey, can you hear me?
>> Yes.
>> What's up? This is uh my second time
joining you. What's up?
>> It is pretty good. Let me ask you,
ma'am. I don't know if we have I asked
you before if you would ever trust a
religion with corrupted scripture. Have
I asked you that before?
>> No, we didn't. We didn't talk about
this. I'm not sure what the subject is
here.
>> Yeah, the subject is Islam is
untrustworthy.
>> Okay. What what makes you say that?
That's your claim that you have to.
>> Exactly. That's why I'm That's why I'm
building up to it. That's why I asked,
would you trust a religion with
corrupted scripture?
>> I wouldn't, but I don't think the Quran
is corrupted.
>> Okay.
>> And that's why I'm not a Christian.
>> I got you. So, you would agree that a
religion that has corrupted scripture is
an untrustworthy religion? Yeah, I would
say so. Well, it depends too because
this is it's not the Quran is not a
written book as you know.
>> It is a written book. What are you
talking about?
>> Well, it is written, but it's it's a
Yeah, but it was it was memorized and
recited and and then later written. So,
>> Okay. All right. No worries. So, the
Quran is in good standing. All right.
What about uh let me ask you, you
believe that the Torah was revealed by
Allah? Of
>> course.
>> And what happened to the Torah? Well,
it's it was corrupted.
>> Okay.
>> As time passed. Yeah. It's not a it's
not an oral tradition, you know, uh
tradition that was preserved.
>> Would you say the same for the Psalms,
the Zabora, and the Gospel that they
were all revealed by Allah, but then
over time corrupted?
>> Yeah. If you if you Yeah. I just believe
in the the gospel as you know, the words
of Jesus. there's still some truths of
course in there. Um and that's why the
Quran well in the gospel and that's why
the Quran
um specifically
mentions some things in the gospel and
um
>> you know edits it to well some of it
yeah you can you can corroborate it
through the Quran.
>> Okay I got you. So the Torah, the
Psalms, the Gospel these are all
revelation of Allah. These were these
are Islamic scriptures and they ended up
getting corrupted. Is that right?
>> Yeah. I'm not I'm not so knowledgeable
on the Psalms. I know the Torah and the
In. So, I'm going to talk, you know, I'm
just No,
>> that's what I know, but it's probably
true.
>> We we we have we have what is called the
Psalms in our Bible today. Do you
believe that that's corrupted or do you
believe it's fully intact?
>> I'm not so sure about the Psalms. I I
I've heard some things from the Psalms,
but I'm not so sure. So, I'm not going
to speak on something I don't know.
>> All right. Fair enough. So let's just
stick with the Torah and gospel then.
The Torah and Gospel maybe the Psalms,
who knows, uh are revelations of Allah
that ended up got getting corrupted. Is
that right?
>> Yes, that's correct.
>> Okay. So you have and then the Quran is
not corrupted. So you got the Torah, the
Gospel. We don't know about the Psalms,
so we'll just put that to the side. But
at least as far as we know, the Torah
and the Gospel have been corrupted.
These are Islamic scriptures that ended
up getting corrupted and then you have
the Quran that's not corrupted. So the
Islam has a few that we know of
according to you corrupted scriptures
within it and so therefore is not
trustworthy.
>> You said Islam has
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Well, there was no promise um in
the Torah and NGO to preserve the word.
So
>> no worries. It's still it's still
untrustworthy then, right? because it's
a religion that has corrupted scriptures
within it.
>> Well, the final revelation that we
believe in is not corrupted.
>> Yeah. But you still
>> and it encompasses everything.
>> But you still got other corrupted
scriptures, right?
>> Yeah. But again, that it's not what we
have today is complete. what we have
today is not, you know, if if the Torah
and the Injil were part one and part two
and we're and this is part three and we
have to use all of it.
>> Um then yeah, but the Quran is here to
be the final revelation and it has
everything that you need. You do not
need the Torah or the Injil
Islam to be complete.
>> Why does Wait, you don't need
>> And as a matter of fact, as a matter
hold on, hold on, hold on. You said a
lot. You said you don't need the Torah
and the Gospel for Islam to be complete.
>> You don't need the Torah and the Gospel
for you to uh be a Muslim and know how
to practice Islam? No, you don't.
>> Okay. Um, did the Quran mention, just
really quick, does the Quran mention
that Muhammad is mentioned in the Torah
and Gospel?
>> Yeah, of course.
>> So, without the Torah and Gospel, how do
you have those references?
>> No, I said you don't need them to
practice and become a Muslim.
>> No, you said you don't need them for
Islam. Islam. You said Islam is still
complete even without those books. How
is that possible if the Quran
continuously references those books as
evidence for Islam?
>> Okay, let me let me just backtrack in
case I I misspoke. What I mean is to
practice Islam, you do not need the
Torah and the Injil. Yes, for proofs
that the prophet Muhammad was there. Um
and um as a matter of fact, the Quran
does, you know, show that it knows the
Torah and the Injil um that it knows it
knows uh it knows things from the Bible
and from the Torah and it consciously
edits it. So there's it's logical that
um you know there's everything that you
need in the Quran and um
>> but it's everything is not in the Quran
because it again it refers to things
outside of it for evidence. So
everything's not in the Quran. Would you
agree?
>> Well, it's it's showing you further
proof that the person the the writer or
the the the ar the author of the Quran
knows the previous scriptures. which
means
>> I'm not I don't I'm not sure why that's
something that's that that would support
your case. It's something that would
support mine.
>> So your case is that Islam is complete
only with the Quran. That's your case
that you're making. But your Quran says
otherwise. It points to other scriptures
for its proof.
>> I didn't say only, by the way, but what
I said was with the Quran, you you have
everything you need to practice being a
Muslim. Yeah. Okay. So, you have the
Torah and Gospel that are corrupted
scriptures within Islam. The Quran is
the only one that has been preserved.
Remember what you said? You said that a
religion that has corrupted scripture is
a religion that is not trustworthy. You
admitted that Islam has at least two
corrupted scriptures within it. So
therefore, Islam is not trustworthy.
>> Again, without the Quran, I probably
would question my religion. But with the
Quran, knowing that it's preserved, I
don't
>> I don't I don't think you're dealing
with the conclusion here. You and I
agreed that a religion that has
corrupted scripture within it is not
trustworthy. You admitted that Islam has
at least two corrupted scriptures within
it, which means Islam is not
trustworthy, but you're still following
it. So if you if you still want to
follow Islam, that that's fine. But just
that acknowledge that you're following a
religion that's not trustworthy.
>> Well, we don't use the Torah and the and
the Inil to
um for the support of why you should
become a Muslim. Again, we revelation
and I would I would pose the same
question to you. I mean follow
scripture, but but the thing is you
don't have a final revelation preserv
Zechariah and you have not addressed the
conclusion here. Please address the
conclusion. Do you admit that you follow
a religion with that that's
untrustworthy because it has corrupted
scripture in it?
>> That doesn't necessarily follow because
there is corruptor scripture doesn't
make a religion untrustworthy.
>> All right, just one second.
>> Getting your violin.
>> No, something else.
>> By the way, with all due respect, I do I
do appreciate these talks, but you do
need to uh you do need to ask people
about their age because you're just
talking to a literal baby.
um sewing seeds as you say. I don't
think we don't do that. First of all,
the Muslims uh don't do that. And yeah,
it's not called sewing seeds. You should
not be talking to minors. I don't think
Christians would appreciate that if
Muslims were doing the same thing.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, shut up everybody in the chat.
Yeah, shut up. Well, you shouldn't be
talking to babies.
>> Stop addressing the chat. I'm I have to
mute you. Just don't talk to the chat,
please. Okay. Maybe we need a visual.
Okay. All right. One, a religion with
corrupted scripture is untrustworthy.
>> I disagree. I'll I'll switch my answer
to that if you want. I disagree.
>> Oh, you disagree with that now?
>> Yeah. All right.
>> I disagree.
>> Okay. So, you believe that a religion
that contains corrupted scripture is
trustworthy. Is that right?
>> That's not That doesn't necessarily
follow, but a religion with
>> Sure.
>> A religion with corrupted scripture. Oh,
just quickly straight up. Is a religion
that has corrupted scripture within it
still trustworthy?
>> Could be. Yes.
>> All right. So, you believe yes. You
switched your answer now. Islam. I mean,
you're you're you're summing up all the
books into all the scriptures into one,
which that's that's not that's that's
not, you know, that just to make
someone's answer seem um you know, wrong
in a way.
>> Uh but again, the final the final
scripture the final scripture does
address that.
>> I don't have to make your answer seem
wrong at all. I think that the audience
with common sense can judge for
themselves. Um and and and you know
that'll be that. So what's today's date?
>> Today is the 19th. The 19th. Yes. It's
been a while. We haven't written in in
the in the red book since the 7th. So
thank you for this.
>> Again, we have a we have
>> about 30 minutes in. We have a final
revelation that addresses the fact that
there is and by the way if you do
believe that if you do believe that the
Torah and the well if you believe the
Inil is corrupted then you're also
following a you know untrustworthy
religion and we do we do believe that
your Bible is corrupted and you know
there are some things that you cannot
reconcile within your own Bible so
>> is still trustworthy I don't know if we
has somebody said this before. I think I
I think somebody might have said this
before. I'm not supposed to write
>> religion twice. A a religion that it's
it's not even about that. God's word,
Allah's word is not untrustworthy. Never
will be. But the edits that people make
with their own hand as the Quran say is
untrust untrustworthy. And that's why we
have to do
>> and that's why we have to see what the
Quran says and the conscious edits that
it makes. So the corrupt Islam is a is a
religion that has corrupted scripture
within it. At first your common sense
told you that that would make a religion
untrustworthy. But because
>> well if you were talking about the Quran
yes because your question makes it
assume as if it's the Quran.
>> It's allow me to land what I'm saying.
>> Sure.
>> Appreciate it. Earlier you said with
your common sense without anything any
without thinking that you were defending
Islam, you answered the question with
your common sense saying yeah a religion
that has corrupted scripture is
untrustworthy.
Once you saw that that worked against
Islam and that Islam had corrupted
scriptures within it, you then changed
your answer and said, "Oh, okay. Well, I
got to change my answer now. Let me go
against my common sense and let me say
actually a religion that has corrupted
scripture is still trustworthy because
your first answer knocks out Islam. So
you're saying that Islam has corrupted
scripture within it yet it is still
trustworthy. Got it?
>> Yes.
>> So this is what I need you to do my
friend. Could you go ahead and give me
evidence of Muhammad's prophethood
before the Quran?
>> What's your point? Okay. Go to the Torah
and the Injil. There is proof of
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait. What? You said
that the Torah and Jill are corrupted.
>> So there's still some truths within it.
So you're agreeing that something that's
corrupted could still have truth within
it.
>> So you're going to corrupted books that
you don't even trust to validate Islam
to validate Muhammad's prophethood?
>> No, that's not that's not the what he
made he made prophecies. We could you
just use that alone?
>> Do you trust the Torah? Well, when we
use the the Quran to see what's what was
corrupted and what was not and what was
consciously
>> edited the Torah or not?
>> By itself,
>> you trust the Quran. Do you trust the
>> by itself? By itself? No. Without the
Quran? No.
>> All right. So, you don't trust the
Torah. Do you trust the Gospel
>> by itself and without uh evidence?
>> Do you trust the gospel?
>> Outside of it? No.
>> Like, for example, ask me the question.
Ask me if I trust the Quran. Ask me.
>> Well, of course, you're going to say no.
>> Ask me. Just Just indulge. Do you trust
the Quran?
>> No, I don't.
>> Do you trust the Torah?
>> Did you see how high I didn't have to
say, "Oh, well, by itself uh with uh you
know, leave things again because we have
a final revelation that that that
consciously edits the the previous
scriptures. It's as easy as that. It's
not a it's not a one. If you continue to
cut cut me off, bro, not about to be
doing this."
>> Do you trust the gospel or not
>> without the Quran? No. Personally,
>> I got you. So, this is what I need you
to do now. So now everything that you do
is through the lens of the Quran, right?
That's how you trust the Torah, the
gospel. That's how you pick what's true
and what's not. That's how you
>> Also, Also, I trust Jesus words, nothing
else.
>> Pause, please. So, what I need you to do
now, show me where the Quran gives you a
reference out of the Torah or the Gospel
where Muhammad is found.
>> What? Can you repeat that again?
>> I'll I'll do it again. No worries. Show
me where the Quran tells you where in
the Torah or the Gospel Muhammad is
mentioned.
>> Where the Quran tells us that?
>> Yeah. Because you only you you can only
go to throughout the Torah and the and
the Gospel through the lens of the
Quran. What the Quran tells you. You
can't trust the Torah Gospel outside of
that. So where does the Quran tell you
where Muhammad is mentioned in the Torah
and Gospel?
>> Well, it says the Let me get you the
quote then.
>> Okay,
>> second.
>> Get the verse. Get the bars.
>> Man, I love this topic. So happy I came
up with it all by myself. I'm so happy
that I came up with these line of
questioning all alone with no help.
>> So there is a verse. I'm in the car. By
the way, I don't have a Quran on me.
Just for those in the chat, but um it
says, "Oh, just one second. Sorry.
>> Get the verse. Get the verse. Shouldn't
take that long to get the verse. Come
on, Zachary. Get the verse." [laughter]
>> I mean, it's there. It's not like you
can't. Oh,
>> someone said life is going to sue you.
Life, who that? The one collecting
YouTube channels like he's collecting
infinity.
>> Can you hear me?
>> Yes, I can hear you.
>> Okay. Uh, I'm out of the app. That's
why. They are the ones who follow the
messengers, the unlettered prophet. Uh,
whose des whose description they find in
their Torah and gospel?
>> Where in the Torah and Gospel? Where
does it say?
>> What do you mean where in the Torah and
Gospel?
>> Does it give you a reference? You you
want the Quran to say exactly in this
verse.
>> Any verse. It doesn't have to be in that
verse. Any verse. Does is there anywhere
in your Quran that tells you where
Muhammad is mentioned in the Torah and
Gospel? Not that he was mentioned. I
know it says it makes the claim that
he's mentioned. [clears throat] Does it
tell you where he's mentioned?
>> That's that's kind of an absurd thing to
ask for to say which line which line in
the Gospel in the Torah it says he's
mentioned.
>> Let me give you an example of this. Let
me give you an example of what I'm
asking you to do. Let me give you an
example. Habibi, watch this. Watch this.
Watch and learn it.
>> No, just because you have an example
doesn't mean you
>> can command the Quran to tell you
exactly
>> you already listen here. You already get
nervous. Let me show you.
>> Not at all. I mean is there's nowhere in
the Quran where it's going to tell you
exactly.
>> Where are you then, Habibi? Let me show
you. Watch this. Look. This is Luke.
This is the NGO. It says in chapter 22,
"And he said, when I sent you out with
no money bag or knapsnacks, knapsacks,
naps snacks or sandals, did you lack
anything?" They said nothing. He said to
them, "But now let the one who has a
money bag take it, and likewise a
knapsack, and let the one who has a no
sword sell his cloak and buy one." Watch
this. For I tell you that this scripture
must be fulfilled in me. Then he quotes
it, and he was numbered with the
transgressors. For what is written about
me has its fulfillment. Huh, Jesus,
since you gave us a direct quote, let's
see if we can find what the heck you're
talking about, Jesus. Cuz if you just
over here making claims that we can't
find, then that would be tough, wouldn't
it? Oh, here it is. Isaiah 53:12.
It says, "Therefore, I will divide him a
portion with the many, and he shall
divide the spoil with the strong,
because he poured out his soul to death
and was numbered with the
transgressors."
Exactly what Jesus quoted. And he was
numbered with the transgressors.
So you see how Jesus gives us a direct
reference that we can go find and see a
direct quote and see what he's talking
about that he says that this is about
him. Does the Quran do that for
Muhammad? When the Quran mentions that
the scripture that Muhammad is the
fulfillment of the scripture or that
he's mentioned in the Torah and the
Gospel, does it tell you where?
>> No. I don't know why are you wasting
your time doing all this. Just because
one book has an exact reference doesn't
mean that the Quran needs to give you an
exact verse to go to.
>> Okay. So your Quran says that Muhammad
is mentioned in the Torah and the
Gospel. Your method your methodology of
trusting the Torah and Gospel is doing
it through the lens of what the Quran
says. Whatever the Qurans tell you and
whatever matches with the Quran, that's
what you take as true. That's what you
take as accurate. Outside of that, if
the Quran don't speak on it, you don't
trust it. If it goes against the Quran,
you don't trust it. So that's why it's
relevant. Your methodology doesn't work.
You say that you have to do this. You go
to the Torah and gospel through the lens
of the Quran, but you can't even use the
Quran. I just Hey, I asked you a basic
question. Your Quran says Muhammad is
mentioned in the Torah and the Gospel.
Where does it claim that he's found? You
can't tell me. So then how can you trust
that the that the Torah and Gospel
contain it?
>> Well, then you go to the Gospel and you
see if that if indeed that person is
mentioned, right? The Torah and the
Gospel and you would see it.
>> All right, show me the
>> Why do you need like why do you need
that? Well, you have to you have to go
deep into into the Psalms. You have to
go deep into the son of man. And I I
don't I don't have that kind of
knowledge right now.
>> Wait, where does your Quran say that
Muhammad is mentioned in the Psalms?
>> I think there is a Psalms that says
that. Where does your Quran say that?
You see how dishonest you have to be as
a Muslim, bro?
>> No, I'm just saying if you do go into
the Psalms, there are some there there
are some that mention. But let's say
let's not say the Psalms. Let's say
>> the Quran say stop. Where does your
Quran say that the Psalms mentions
Muhammad?
>> It doesn't say that.
>> Then where are you getting it from that
the Psalms mentions Muhammad? You only
look at these previous scriptures
through the lens of the Quran. But do
you see how you're do you see how you're
going to the Psalms without the Quran
telling you to go to the Psalms? You see
how you're doing that?
>> I I don't get what's your point here.
Like you want an exact You want an exact
like
>> is that your methodology is
untrustworthy. You don't even trust what
you're saying. You're saying that this
is how you do things. This is how you
see things. This is how you trust
things. But you're not even using that
method to do it. You said you do it
through the lens of the Quran, but
you're going to the Psalms when the
Quran doesn't mention it. The Quran
doesn't say Muhammad's mentioned in the
Psalms.
>> Well, you don't need you don't need to
go into the the Torah or the Inil even
to to see, you know, the prophet
Muhammad. There there is prophecies
there is things in the Quran itself that
that tells you
>> do you see how you got to go back to the
Quran
>> again? Even without the Quran, there's
prophecies that are attested. the Quran,
you have no evidence for Muhammad's
prophethood, even though your Quran
points to things outside of itself for
Muhammad's prophethood. Again, I'll ask
you, demonstrate to me Muhammad's
prophethood before the Quran.
>> How can we do that before the Quran if
if he's if he's the prophet that was
sent that message?
>> Huh? You should ask the Quran that. What
What was the verse that you read to me?
>> What? The unlettered prophet.
>> What did it say? What does it say about
him? that they find in their uh sure in
their Torah and gospel. Sure.
>> So, how do we how do you demonstrate
Muhammad's prophethood before the Quran?
>> Well, if you go to your Bible, there is
mentions of someone coming after Jesus.
It's just not clear. It's not saying
Muhammad that will bring the Quran,
right? Even your Bible doesn't say that.
>> Okay, show me. Let You know what? I'll
grant you this. Show me this. Show me
this where Jesus talks about somebody
coming after him. Show me this. What
What chapter and verse?
>> I don't have that. I It's a son of man
that you and Liiano has talked about
many times saying that it's Jesus, but
we think it's Muhammad.
>> You think the son of man is Muhammad?
>> Yes.
>> Where is the son of man mentioned?
>> Again, I'm not going to go into it. You
can talk about that with Libya. I know
who you brought this. I'm telling you.
No, no, no. I said is the son of man. I
before I even started, I said this is
not something that I
>> I got you. Don't worry. You're trying so
hard to go into topics that someone
doesn't know. But what you're the
untrustworthy one right now who's trying
to put me in a topic that I I'm I'm
telling you I don't have I don't have
the knowledge on this right now. You can
go to talk to someone who's sure you can
talk to someone who's more knowledgeable
on this subject. If anything trust
[sighs]
>> Are you done? Are you done crying about
me challenging you to prove the things
you say? You done? Do you see what the
violin does? It It calms us down. It
brings serenity. You mentioned You
mentioned that the son of man is
Muhammad. You said it. Not Libyan.
Liiano ain't brave enough to be here.
You're brave enough to be here.
>> Not Libyano. You are. You're brave
enough to step up to the plate and make
these claims on my stream. You're gonna
you're going to get sad when I challenge
you on it.
>> Hold on. I was getting a call. Can you
hear me?
>> Oh, you're getting a call. You You can
hear me, right? Don't try to play games.
You can hear me, right? Yeah, he's
playing games. All right, Zachary, I
appreciate you for coming, man. You gave
us a good clip. Take care of yourself.
The son of man is Muhammad. The son of
man is Muhammad. Let's read about the
son of man. Let's read about the son of
man. And we're going to demonstrate the
polytheism within Islam because Muslims
are so desperate for Muhammad to be
Jesus. They wish Muhammad was Jesus. The
Quran wishes Muhammad was Jesus. The
Hadith wishes Muhammad was Jesus. Takes
from the titles and qualifications,
qualities, actions, deeds, and works of
Jesus. Tries to apply that and spread it
in between Allah and Ma. Allah can have
some of the attributes of Jesus and then
Muhammad can have some other attributes
of Jesus. They wish Muhammad was Jesus.
Y'all don't got him though. Y'all don't
got Jesus. Let's go ahead and read about
this son of man. The devil is a liar.
This is who you're saying Muham you
believe Muhammad is. Okay, let's go
ahead and read about the son of man,
guys. And you tell me that these Muslims
aren't polytheists. Pagan polytheist.
Watch what it says. Verse 31, Matthew
25. When the son of man comes in his
glory, Muhammad's going to come in his
glory. This Muhammad Muhammad comes and
he has glory that he comes in. What? You
believe this? According to the Quran, it
says that Allah's going to come ride in
the clouds. He's going to come with the
clouds and the angels. That's what the
Quran says. This says it's the son of
man who's going to come in his glory.
Uh-oh. Muhammad's going to come from
where? He's dead. Where Muhammad coming
from? Huh? Hey, hey, where where
Muhammad coming from? Huh? The grave. He
going to pop out the dirt from under the
cabba. Okay, watch this. When the son of
man comes in his glory and all the
angels with him, the angels Muhammad's
going to be coming. Man, you guys don't
believe me, huh? Y'all y'all don't think
Y'all don't believe me when I say that
they wish that Muhammad was Jesus. They
wish that Allah was Jesus. Let me show
y'all what I'm talking about. Did y'all
just hear this? The son of Who's coming?
The son of man is coming in his glory
with the angels. Watch this, y'all. Let
me just get this verse. It's in uh in
the 80s. Hold on, man. Y'all having me
bring out my notes, man. I ain't I ain't
used this verse in a minute, so I don't
got it off the top of my head like that.
But we ain't going to let y'all get away
with it. Watch this, y'all. Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh,
yeah. Yeah. Chapter 89. Watch this,
y'all. Watch. Watch us get the verse.
Watch us get the verse in the Quran.
Chapter 89, starting at verse 21. Watch
us get the verse. The only thing we do
is right there. We just read it. Now,
watch this. Watch what it says. No, when
the earth has been leveled, pounded, and
crushed. When the earth is finished,
y'all, this is talking about end times.
What's going to happen? And your Lord
has come and the angels. Rank upon rank.
So, who's coming? Your Lord, Muslims,
supposedly your Lord is coming on that
day that the earth is finished, leveled.
But who's he coming with? He's coming
with the angels. Y'all think this is
Muhammad? Y'all see how polytheistic
y'all are? Full of polytheism. Y'all are
polytheistic. The son of man comes in
his glory with the angels at the last
day. The Muslims in the Quran, it says
Allah, their Lord is going to do it.
Unless they think that their Lord is
Muhammad, he's going to come with the
angels. And guess what the son of man
going to do? He going to sit on his
glorious throne. What belove?
You mean to tell me that the son of man
is gonna come and he has glory and he
comes with the angels and he has a
glorious throne he's going to sit on
WHAT YOU THINK THIS IS Muhammad Sherk
Sheralicious
it's fine time sherkalicious
Muhammad's going to whine and dine
Sheralicious
yeah Sheralicious
happy sharks given ladies and gentlemen
watch what they say Muhammad's going to
do the son of man god forbid Before him
will be gathered all the nations and he
will separate people from one another as
a shepherd separates the sheep from the
goats. This Muhammad sharkalicious.
It's fire time. Shalicious. Muhammad's
going to whine and die. Shiralicious.
This Muhammad. Muhammad has a glorious
throne. He's going to come on the day of
judgment in his glory with the angels.
Something that Allah is supposed to be
doing. Shiralicious. Oh yeah.
Shiralicious. Oh, it's it's Sherks
giving, y'all. It's Sherksgiving week.
I'm telling you. Let's keep reading
because IT GETS BETTER. WATCH WHAT HE
SAYS. And he will separate people from
one another as a shepherd separates the
sheep from the goats. You mean to tell
me that Muhammad is going to be the one
on judgment day separating believers
from non-believers? Shiralicious. It's
fine time. Shiralicious. Muhammad's
going to want it done. Shiralicious.
Yeah. Yeah. Shirkalicious.
Happy Sharks Given, y'all. It gets
better. And he will place the sheep on
his right, but the goats on his left.
Then the king. Wait a second. The king.
Muslims. Y'all believe that Muhammad is
the king of the day of judgment. That's
that's Allah's title. In chapter one,
depending on which Quran you read, it
says that he is the king of the day of
judgment. But here it says the son of
man is the king of the day of judgment.
Y'all believe this is Muhammad.
Muhammad's the son, the son of man who's
the king of the day of judgment. A title
belonging only to Allah. Shiralicious.
It's fine time. Shiralicious. Muhammad's
going to wind and dine. Shiralicious.
Yeah. Yeah. Shalicious.
Oh yeah. It's Shark Week, ladies and
gentlemen. I know y'all love it. Get
your ladies, grab your fellas, hit the
dance floor because it's Sharkalicious.
It's fine and die. Shalicious.
Muhamad's gonna whine and die.
Shiralicious. Come on, y'all. Yeah.
Yeah. Shalicious. Hit the desk, fellas.
Yeah. Yeah. Get your shirt on. It gets
better. Y'all thought that was it, huh?
Hey. Hey. You thought that was it, huh?
That ain't it, Libbyiano. This this this
your man. Y'all y'all y'all y'all want
to copy Liiano's Flippiano's arguments?
Let me show you how much trouble he gets
you in. Watch this. It gets better.
Let's keep going, ladies and gents.
Watch what it says. The Then the king
will say to those on his right, "Come,
you who are blessed by my father."
What you mean? Is the son of man is the
son of God? So Muhammad is the son of
Allah. Oopsie. Shiralicious. It's fine
time. Shiralicious.
Mohamad's gonna wind. Sheralicious.
Yeah. Yeah. Shalicious.
Yeah. Yeah. Happy Sharksgiving, ladies
and gentlemen. Y'all. And that right
there is the moment where we go ahead
because Muslims are so desperate to find
Muhammad in our scriptures because the
Quran says it. Even though their
religion is completely untrustworthy,
they have no references to where
Muhammad's found. So they have to jump
into our scripture and commit blasphemy,
commit sherk according to Islamic
standards, meaning associating a partner
with Allah, saying that somebody is
equal with Allah or somebody is on par
with Allah. That's what sherk is. They
have to commit sherk, which is the
unforgivable sin according to Islam in
chapter 4. All these Muslims might as
well come to Christian. Yeah, y'all got
a Islam is not going to save y'all. For
y'all that that just committed the
sherk, it's over for you. You cannot and
will not be forgiven for sherk. Sorry.
It's over for you. Come to the gospel.
They will commit sherk in order to try
to plug Muhammad in the scriptures.
They're that desperate. You see how
Satan works? They're that desperate.
What a clown religion. Clown religion.
And they do this only because of one
reason. And this is a reason we all have
to remember. There's no fighting it.
There's no resisting it. As long as Give
me f I give me f but [music] I give me f
I give me f but f I give me f. [music]
>> We going to commit shirt day after day.
[music]
>> [music]
>> I
>> Muslims, stop repeating these stupid,
damnable arguments from your da guys.
They will get you on the stream like
this and they will get you humiliated.
You're going to be embarrassed. You're
going to be embarrassed. You're lucky
it's me. You're lucky you're you're
lucky it's not on Christian Prince's
Live or Rob Christian or somebody else.
They they will humiliate you even worse
than than than I do. But it's not our
fault. You're listening and picking up
arguments from these dumb da guys and
you're just gullible sheep repeating the
stupidity like a brainless bot and
coming up here as if it sounds good and
then cry when you get challenged on what
you're saying.
Snackbot.